hey guys I'm out of the country at the
moment but we didn't want to leave you
hanging with no clips so here's just
some general Insanity of the day do you
have any regrets about taking your own
Vision or the process with which you you
did take your own Vision I don't have
any regrets taking my vision
I believe I should have been born blind
and I'm happy the way I am
I do have some regrets about the way I
did it but I'm in the end I'm happy the
way I am Dr Phil
I with all due respect to Jewel but I am
having a really hard time really hard
time
sitting so close to someone who
traumatized herself who damaged herself
we took an oath in medicine to help
people we see horrible tragedies every
single day as doctors and people who
would give anything to go back and
restore their Vision their health my
heart is beating out of my chest I can't
even make sense of the emotions I'm
feeling because to hear someone say I've
I've always felt I should be blind well
I've always felt I should be the queen
of England but I'm not going out to
become the Queen of England
bro